Oh
it only figures to celebrate Christmas
Day with a Christmas movie and the
Muppet Christmas Carol seems to be a
good one to talk about it's so
interesting that for so many younger
people this is their introduction to the
classic Charles Dickens tale I should
see that is a bad thing seeing how the
Mickey Christmas Carol was my
introduction to it and truth be told
it's not a bad way to be introduced is
it the best way no but I think it's
still pretty reasonably well done Ellen
easer Scrooge played by Michael Caine is
the town's most hated man one of his
workers Bob Cratchit played by Kermit
the Frog and yes I know somebody else
please Kermit the Frog but come I work
with me here
tries to get Christmas day off to spend
with his family after Scrooge
begrudgingly agrees he's told that he's
going to be haunted by three ghosts that
night the ghost of Christmas past
present and future each one shows him
exactly that the past president future
and slowly over the course of the film
Scrooge starts to realize the importance
of Christmas the importance of being
nice and the importance of sharing his
wealth with puppets half his size the
film is pretty by-the-book and following
the original story they have gonzo and
Rizzo as the narrators who constantly
get beaten up throughout the entire
movie and all the other Muppet
characters play the parts that we know
from the book the one that actually has
me pissing my pants with laughter is
fozziwig by god I swear this whole movie
was put together just so they could do
that pun on the whole it's a decent film
especially when you look at the sets and
the atmosphere and the colors it's clear
the focus of the movie was not to tell a
great Muppet film but rather a decent
Christmas carol now the downside is some
might find that as a turn off as someone
who loves the Muppet movie and the
Muppet Caper in their early films I
really thought there was going to be a
lot more humour to this like if you saw
the Muppets do a Christmas carol on say
The Muppet Show you know everything
would go wrong their personalities will
get in the way and be all crazy and
stuff will be blowing up and falling
apart but here it's got to be done more
seriously which isn't a bad thing I
guess it just doesn't feel that Muppet
is half the time but even that's made up
for when they do something actually a
little different from the story stuff
that maybe other versions should
consider putting in one
my favorite additions is that the ghost
of Christmas present has a bad memory
why because he's always living in the
present
so sometimes he'll repeat things like
he'll introduce himself twice or say a
sentence he already said that's a really
clever idea I also love the design of
the ghost of Christmas past that's kind
of a baby but kind of an adult too is
sort of ageless but there are definitely
some moments that are by no means
terrible but can definitely be a little
awkward well the songs for the most part
are pretty damn good some of them almost
sound a little too cleaned up like the
love is gone is sung almost a little too
nice you almost miss the emotion of it
and let's get to the part that's really
gonna make you want to kill me I don't
think Michael Caine is that greatest
group you heard right I don't think he's
awful but there are just so many moments
where I feel like he's really just
phoning it in for example what the fuck
is this it just cracks me up how weird
it is there's also some line deliveries
that just feel lazy to me if I look at
this scene we just sort of called Bob
Cratchit's name and it just sounds like
really bad acting mr. Scrooge Bob Bob
Cratchit does anyone else feel that was
just kind of half-assed but the big is
seen and I mean quite literally the
biggest scene is when he's supposed to
break down and change his ways there's
no big music there's no big visuals for
it it all just relies on his performance
and I'm sorry it doesn't deliver I don't
feel a thing for this guy he's the
Scrooge I wouldn't live my life in the
past the present of the future I will
not shut out the lessons the spirits of
doping I don't entirely blame him as the
staging and pacing in the scene is kind
of weird too but I think of all the
other Scrooge's and how I felt so bad
for them and they just made this such a
huge scene and here it's just a guy who
looks like he's trying to be sad while
saying some lines but with all that said
I'd say only about half of the
performance is not very good there
actually is a half that's pretty decent
and strangely enough a lot of it's in
the musical numbers Michael Caine is not
a very good singer but he
it does put a lot of passion when he's
doing the singing roles he actually does
feel very jubilant wasting in the final
song and I really love the addition of
having him sing a duet with the version
of his past love that's a great idea and
he does it very well he also has the
threatening looking stamina of a proper
Scrooge so I can't say he's terrible
because when he does something good it
is good but for me it's only about half
the performance I don't know it could
very well be that I love Christmas
carols so much and I love the character
of Scrooge that I really really hold
them to a high standard in fact honestly
I can probably count on my one hand how
many great Scrooge's I think that really
are that I've seen but still that's not
what you're coming to see you're coming
to see the Muppets and the Muppets do
fine
even though I don't feel like it's a
traditional Muppet movie I do kind of
give it credit that it tried to do
something really serious
they still address a lot of the dark
stuff they still kill off Tiny Tim this
could so easily be awkward and laughably
done but it's actually pretty legit and
yeah like a lot of people i watch it
every year too it's a strange combo but
a decent one the kids will enjoy the
puppets the adults will enjoy the jokes
and the Christmas lovers will enjoy
Christmas have a wonderful holiday and
possibly pop this film in